tickets for the big game are
skyrocketing as demand prices out all
but the wealthiest bidders my ticket was
so expensive I had to rescind my pledge
to the March of Dimes
I know
next year but thanks in part to online
resellers the world's Uber Rich are
gobbling up all the seats sounds
delicious yeah the rich are eating up
all the tickets while telling us to eat
up all the crickets
of course something's only worth what
people are willing to pay right that's
why news Nation pays Chris Cuomo in
compliments
but now it's Bonkers some tickets are
going up to 33 Grand it's chump change
for me but a life-saving operation for
that orphan who claims he's my son
even you know even the cheapest seat on
sites like StubHub or SeatGeek will cost
you over 4 500 bucks and that's just for
a seat in the men's room third stall
from the right on the mezzanine
tap twice so as the game looms closer
the disparity between the ruling class
and average Americans couldn't be
farther apart if it were the Gap in
Michael Strahan's teeth
obviously regular folks can't afford to
attend the Super Bowl luckily I'll be
going but my writers will be watching
through a window outside Buffalo Wild
Wings
all right
Aaron
um isn't it seem weird that like all the
fans really can't afford to see the game
and the people who goes to see the games
are just rich people doesn't that bother
you and am I sounding like a Marxist
well I won't comment on the Marxist
thing but this is a first class problem
I don't have to worry about because the
Buffalo Bills just completely collapsed
at the end of the season and they don't
get to go to the Super Bowl I would
gladly pay thousands of dollars to watch
the Buffalo Bills if they ever made it
to a Super Bowl once in my life but the
NFL had a debacle in 2015 when it came
to tickets and resellers and people
being able to these Brokers being able
to sell tickets and then the tickets not
being available so they had to try and
coalesce the ability to sell these
tickets the NFL has made themselves an
incredibly profitable Market when it
comes to not only games but viewership
53 million people watch the AFC
Championship and that was a terrible
game and terribly officiated so now they
have to be able to keep the control of
their product to make sure they can
maintain the growing value right you saw
cap space go up this year when it comes
to NFL players and teams being able to
buy more Talent they have to be able to
fund that some way and being able to
sell Super Bowl tickets is that way and
if the Buffalo Bills ever in my lifetime
go I will auction off anything I can to
be able to buy a ticket and watch them
play and maybe hopefully someday win I
wish I cared as much about anything as
you care about the bus oh yes I love it
it's amazing we got a chick on the show
knows football it's like a unicorn well
you know there's one you know I should
say I try to remove myself from deeply
caring about politics since it is my
profession so I just put all of that
rage and angst into my football team
collapsing so epically versus the
Cincinnati Bengals and I was in Orchard
Park for the game and as you can tell
still deeply angry about it okay the
Bengals are the ones with the orange
pants yeah you would like the Buffalo
Bill Sports gal too that's right Pat you
would love the Buffalo Bills because
they're named after the killer in
Silence of the Lambs nope that's not
true throw each other through tables
before the game we do that yes like pro
wrestling you sure do I actually would
love to go to this Super Bowl why
because it's in Arizona and I wouldn't
be cold yeah it is true football is like
boring boring and cold yeah but the
indoors yeah it's in Vegas too Larry's
gonna explode right now
The Stadium seats 73 000 people yes
that's right so every seat will be
filled exactly there's we have seven
three rich people supply and demand I
know we're off to a good start in this
show and you were describing all these
economic factors okay you need to stay
with okay okay let me let me let me
paint a picture for you a normal game do
you like a team do you have a favorite
team absolutely what's your favorite
team is it the Buffalo Giants all right
so you're a Giants fan you're good all
right stop it stop it
he likes the Chicago black socks
said that too but no okay so get this
you're at a Giants game what's it like
it's alive it's chaotic there's fights
there's people screaming why because
there are fans there right they're fans
you go and you watch the Super Bowl and
it's like people like they've got their
they've got their Sushi they got their
plate of sushi and they're all like
polite and they're all in their boxes oh
look there's Taylor Swift and she's with
you know Donny Osmond and I'm like and
I'm at home and I'm a fan I'm a fan but
I'm not there that upsets me Mr moneybag
man that was a tough one I sat through
that money bag I'm gonna change the name
of your show to that yes
just you know we left Adam Smith in
Scotland in that binary discussion we
had he was the guy who invented supply
and demand right I don't know why you're
so hot and bothered about this it's just
a couple of bucks to see a football game
a couple of bucks to you forty four
hundred dollars oh yeah be like me I'm
on the street man I know what's going
down yeah you know you've you've you've
just like become such a different person
I love that this article was like it's a
far cry from the average twelve dollars
would have cost in 1967. I could have
bought a lot of things like a home yes
you could that's a Perfect Analogy you
can't afford a home and the Super Bowl
ticket is worth a home the free market
works oh yes like those chickens you
were talking about earlier they all
deserve to die can we get back to the
translation
I said I got some thoughts got some
ideas I'm just kidding what do you
identify as what if you identify as a
wealthy person yeah and that let me in
yeah I'll say this it's still free on TV
right what are you crying about yeah but
you know what that's the deal yeah
very pragmatic
headache things cost money what
what is that like can you believe my
poor kids because I have no job can't
get Jordans yeah they're expensive he
said there's no such thing as a free
lunch Adam Smith Milton Friedman oh
everybody
Milton don't call me Adam Smith Freeman
do your homework they get so pissed off
when you confused people in the Gilded
Age would have loved this NFL
Championship well you know what I just
think it's gonna get it's crazy it's
crazy it's just to me it's crazy but
you're obviously on the whole it's a
necessary evil right it's part of
capitalism it says wonderful supply and
demand that we're so keen on it 20
minutes ago it's amazing next year I
think you're accusing me of being very
superficial which he's right yeah he's
very right like I'll just change my mind
I might actually change my mind in the
break you just have to get the influence
you'll be at the Super Bowl he's just
talking about how he's right
he's one of us dude
all right are we done here do you want
anything else I can't remember if I
talked to you about this I'm having
orange pants yes that's right the
Bangles have orange pants and it's cold
yes all right I've never been to Arizona
in February it's very cold there too
it's a beautiful place hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else